the stuff that I've been focusing on
over the last couple of years is is
making my audience my clients aware of
the changes that are happening and
having them try and disassociate from
political change as a way to improve our
lives and improve our well-being and
focus more on individual change what do
I need to do to change my life to make
sure that over the next 20 years I
prosper I thrive not that I survive but
that I actually thrive and it's a I mean
it's a full-time job just going through
all that because we want to be focused
on the stuff that doesn't matter
we love focusing on the noise but the
noise doesn't make you any money the
noise doesn't protect you the noise just
distracts you
keeps you dependent and apathetic
Jason's stable turn in the building how
you doing man I'm doing well brother
thank you for having me on your show
thank you for being here dude what's
been going on what you've been doing
today well today I've been doing a lot
of it's so funny because the bolt people
think that what I do is yeah I mean some
of what I do is cool and some of it is
is celebrity I guess in terms of how it
looks in two places I get a go I live in
Los Angeles so I get a I get a go to a
lot of premieres and stuff like that but
the bulk of what I do is sitting in a
room staring at a computer screen
looking over numbers for marketing and
advertising and that's what I was doing
today I'm actually writing sales copy
and I was building out a bunch of sales
funnels for some YouTube advertising
that we're doing so it was it's not
glamorous work it's not sexy but it's
it's it's oftentimes that's the work
that really pays the big money that's
where the dividends are made it's not
when people are seeing you it's not when
you're on Instagram or Facebook or
anything like that it's when you're
bunkered down in your room when nobody's
looking at you doing the stuff that
nobody else is willing to do I always
say you know success success happens
when nobody's watching and and I guess I
was involved in a little bit of that
this morning that's cool yeah I always
think about Conor McGregor you know
people look at this guy and he's
essentially unlimited wealth now and
there's a bunch of things that he is
capable of doing that pretty much no one
else's
however Conor's had two kids over the
last few years
Conor McGregor as a dad has had to get
up at 3 in the morning and change your
dirty nappy like that is just reality
there's some things that you have to do
that you can't stop doing right there's
this quote I think it's a rasmus that
says from the king in his castle to the
peasant in the street everybody shits
it's like there are certain parts of
life you just can't get away from and
you know you you write as well like as a
good promoter people see you standing on
the front door of a nightclub and they
just think it's like strippers and
cocaine until 6:00 in the morning
the wake up like throw the condoms in
the bin have some cereal and a Budweiser
and crack back on I'm like no like
absolutely not I'm the guy that has to
sit in the office and argue with the
manager because they
till floats off and all this stuff so
yeah I think no matter your industry
you're always gonna have to do the grind
no it's funny when you talk about
McGregor one of the things that I was
always I really loved about him he he
you've got video of him going back to
when he was a nobody from nowhere and
not only what's always impressed me
about him is that personality of his
existed long before he was wearing the
pants for it right back when he did Iike
I mean he hadn't won anything of note
but he knew somewhere deep in his soul
that he was going to be the Muhammad Ali
of the MMA world and and he went at it
with the ferocity and with just a cold
unwavering belief that it was possible
and I just I think that's necessary for
any amount of success in life you have
to believe it in yourself first before
anybody else will believe it and before
you're ever gonna be able to achieve
what you want I I you know people
different some people love him some
people hate him I absolutely love him as
a fighter but I love him more for the
industry that he's built around himself
he's made himself into a true icon and
for anybody who studies influence or or
or brand building man he is somebody
that you have to look at because he's
just done it perfectly
he's a baseman he really really is yeah
it's a it's interesting that right
because I talk a lot about integrity and
virtue and living your truth and
speaking the truth and in the same
breath I can totally see that fake it
till you make it or kind of believe it
ahead of way your achievements are at is
also a worthwhile and virtuous thing to
do you know like I I genuinely believed
that I could become the best podcaster
in the UK I think that there's episodes
I've put out that some of the best
content that's ever come out from the UK
an episode with Aubrey Marcus maybe this
one with you as well and you know like I
feel proud of that I don't feel like
that's I don't feel like that's being um
unethical I don't feel like I'm I'm
kidding myself or the people that I say
that to
but you know like leading first leading
with your confidence first yeah I think
someone that Conor McGregor's a good a
good role model for that you know he's
living in his parents attic on welfare
like with this same missus that he's got
now like just yeah girl some chick who's
now you know got a husband that's worth
probably 100 mil of plus whatever it is
you know you're easy yeah no I uh I've
been a I'm always a big fan that change
happens first in the mind I mean we were
talking a lot of self-help stuff here
but in reality if you want your life to
change it you first have to have a
vision of that change you have to know
what you want and you have to see it in
your eyes so you'd have a kind of a
destination to aim for that's in terms
of like lying to yourself that's where I
like to lie to myself I don't lie to
myself about where I'm at right now or
about what my current skill set is but I
do lie to myself about where I could be
and what I want to have because I think
that in order for me to move forward I I
have to have that vision and I have to
believe that I can get there so yeah I'm
a huge proponent of that I talk a lot
about negative feedback loops with with
my clients because so many of them
struggle with any time you're building a
new company or you're starting something
from scratch it's it's a lot more
failure than success and that that
always it always hurts and it's really
really easy to say well I just keep
digging and digging and I'm not hitting
any gold and eventually they're just
gonna give up and walk away and and the
truth is is that that it's the same for
everybody everybody wakes up and is in
works for months or for sometimes years
and don't see huge results from it and
then all of a sudden all of that
culminates into really vertical and
explosive growth in your company and
your your life can change I mean I
struggle for several years with a couple
of different businesses that just failed
miserably until I started my you know my
my trading and an investment company
that about ten years ago and it's so
funny because I couldn't make money as
an entrepreneur for the first five or
six years and then I start this one
company and within within 18 months I've
made just short of a million dollars in
the next year I made a million and a
half dollars a year after that I mean
or two million dollars you just like you
know you said well what happened what
what changed and nothing changed you
just you learned and you advanced and
you grew and you took your licks and you
adjusted and you just kept going because
I knew that I couldn't do anything else
like I just I had I'm unemployable at
this point like no one I like the people
could hire me I guess people would try
and hire me but I couldn't work for
somebody else it's just this is the only
choice there's no place to fall back to
success must happen and so when you find
yourself in that situation
it creates I don't know and you're doing
things that you love it just creates all
kinds of I don't know all kinds of
spirit and passion and what you do and
so what I would I work with people on is
a get out of that negative feedback loop
if you haven't had any successes in your
life and you're waking up in the morning
and you saying what do I have to be
proud of what do I have to be grateful
for I say start with the carpet under
your feet you know start with the hot
water in your shower because the bulk of
mankind doesn't have it if you need a
success for the day
get up when your alarm goes off because
there's a ton of people who can't even
do that and when the alarm goes off get
up and just like boom I'm winning I'm
winning because I promised myself that
when the alarm went off I get out of bed
and I did and if I can do that then I
can do the next thing and over time
those little wins turn into big wins and
it is it it really it is life changing
these little tiny tweaks that we make to
the way we think and the way we and like
you said in some cases lie to ourselves
yeah for sure Bill Gates says people
underestimate what they can achieve in
overestimate what they can achieve in
one year and underestimate what they can
achieve in five and from James clears
atomic habits as well he talks about
taking for you it would be you took six
years to become an overnight success
which is by the way what a great book he
wrote I actually you know that he's got
that I'd look at the grass just I've
even used the grass and some of the
stuff that I used to teach with I and
because it's so powerful it's a great
book it's one of the best so The Linde
effect right you know the yeah life
lifespan of non-perishable
items if a books been around like 1984
has been around for about 50 years movie
7 years actually you can preview it will
be around for another 70 what it means
is that we should probably be a little
bit more cautious about the stuff that
we read or consume which has been
consumed consumed produce recently which
is interesting that probably 99% of
everything that we consume has been
produced within last 24 hours
stories all the rest of it that's not
Lindy right
but James clears atomic habits is one
that books the trend you know that book
absolutely will be 10 years 20 years
time I think because it's just so so
seminal it'll be as applicable in in a
hundred years as it is today because
human nature doesn't change we you know
we were the same people today as we will
be a hundred years from now you go back
and look at sales copy written in the
1800s when people didn't even really
know what they were doing yet and we
still use we go back if you're a
copywriter or a marketing guy we'll go
back and look at that stuff and refer to
it as training tools because it's so
good and it's the same today
so yeah his books gonna go his book is
gonna be a like a historical book it'll
be good husband year beastmon he was on
he was on here last year and I was just
blown away by him I'm talking about
sales coffee actually
Richard shot in previous modern ways
from guess and he's coming on soon he
told me he did an analysis of the number
of new words that we used in adverts and
there's been a significant downturn in
the number of new words and this isn't
that words are being used up it's to do
with the fact that people in ad agencies
and copywriters are playing it safe
increasingly more and more and the quote
that he has is he says people would
rather fail safely than win with risk
because if you fail if you put an advert
out that was maybe a little bit
adventurous and it fails it's totally on
your head whereas if you put something
out that just oh well you know that kind
of looked like the the what all of our
competitors did it's a surprise that
that didn't work no worries you know you
kind of get a pat on the back that try
again yeah and that's that's so
interesting how the marketing
the marketing industry is moving like
that you know it's like ego yeah we used
the template and we use the template it
didn't work you can't blame me because
it's the template that we always use
well yeah like we remember those ads it
would have been a few years ago and the
ads were like she thought it was all
over and then he did this for a while
like you were clicking on all of them
yeah and then after about three weeks
you're like dude I've seen five hundred
of these and everybody's doing it and
none of them work and most recently
everybody's video has to have like this
banner box around it that's got writing
at the top and something at the bottom
yeah right so it all looks the same and
it's like yeah if that's what you do if
you play it safe if you don't push the
envelope if your I always say if you're
not looking at what 90% of people are
doing and then doing the opposite well
you you're wrong but there comes a point
in advertising it's it's cycles where
you look you got to get off of what
everybody else is doing because that's
been saturated and you're right you
won't you might not lose your job for it
but you're never gonna get rich doing it
that way you you've got to constantly be
pushing the envelope and testing new
things and trying new things at the risk
of failing because that's the only way
we learn I love it Mon so you were
talking about negative thought loops and
and and how people can start to move
themselves out of that have you got some
other things that you do with your
clients to kind of foundational things
like how are you viewing yourself how
are you viewing the day how are you
going about your purpose and meaning and
things like that yeah it depends on
where the clients at so early on in the
process when I'm talking with people one
of the first things I want them to
understand and to work on is that we
really live in the greatest period in
human history I I firmly believe that I
used for example what we're doing right
here I were just having a Skype
conversation over video the first time I
went overseas it was 2005 I was in Iraq
at the time and I was working for a
contracting company and I I could not
video call my at the time my wife during
that process because that there was
enough bandwidth to do that and we had
we had pretty good internet there as
well and when I first started my company
in 2000 in 2009 but we really kind of
moved into our first space in 2010 I had
to put make all of the videos that I put
online available for download because
anybody who wasn't in a major
metropolitan city oftentimes didn't have
the ability to stream high-definition
videos I'm not talking 1080 I was like
like 720p video so the low high
definition and especially if you lived
outside the country you couldn't do it
now boom cell phone cell phone I was
streaming the other day of a big
presentation - about 600 people and we
were out on Facebook YouTube streaming
live over like our own internal network
and all of that at the same time and
people are watching it on their cell
phones just like the world that we live
in today is unreal it has never been
cheaper or easier to really take control
of your life and to build your business
build your life the way you want it and
and I said the second thing that I tell
people is you know for the first time in
human history we get to consider
personal fulfillment in what we do for
work and if you go back fit even 50
years the idea that your grandfather got
up every day and went oh I wonder what
would fulfill me as a person today and
the work that I do know my grandfather's
father was a farmer he was a farmer you
know my father went to law school
because that's what my dad my
grandfather wanted him to do right so
personal fulfillment wasn't even a
consideration and now in 2020 where we
live today there is every single human
being especially watching this has the
ability to consider and to pursue
personal fulfillment as part of what
they do to earn their living
and I just I think that's amazing I just
I other people look at this world and
like everybody's suffering and then
everything's going to hell in a
handbasket it's all crap and the truth
is I believe completely the opposite and
is I think it's one of the reasons that
I've had more success maybe than a lot
of people is bee
mentally my mindset is just one that
says I'm surrounded by abundance I'm
surrounded by opportunity and all I got
to do is figure out how to harness that
and how to how to bend it to me and so
that's what I try and get people to do
first is to shift their mindset to one
of I'm surrounded by opportunity I just
have to figure out how to harness that
and direct it towards me I wonder how
many people struggle with this
existential crisis this lack of purpose
and meaning precisely because there is
this paradox of choice now you know like
if you're not being fulfilled now there
are fewer excuses than there were fifty
years ago that's not to say that there
aren't people who you know have
disadvantages where they can't get
themselves to the stage where work is
joy for them and blah blah but there's
fewer reasons for that and there is more
onus on you there's a a really
interesting point by Alain de Botton
from the School of Life where he talks
about modern world is a meritocracy
right and if the successes of the people
who do well are theirs to bear that
means that the failures of people who do
badly must be also dares to bear I think
absolutely
now that is a very difficult pill to
swallow I Phi as I do with most things
and I just say you know the most
important phrase that you can learn is
it's my fault and if you will learn that
everything if you will accept
responsibility for everything I don't
care whether it is your fault or not
just accept responsibility for it
what you're really saying is all the
successes that I'm in control of my life
that I get to direct where I want my
life to go and what I want to have and
what I want to be and nobody can keep me
from that so if I'm not there right now
it's my fault
far from being something that's negative
it's it's very liberating because once
you recognize that you are what you have
and what you want to achieve is
completely up to you it opens the world
up the problem is most people live a
life of mediocrity somewhere between
total failure and their true potential
and so they as I say they go only so far
and then they
and then they look at their life and
they feel terrible about it because they
don't have what they want and instead of
looking internally and saying what do I
need to change about me they start
pointing fingers externally and saying
it's odds cuz my boss doesn't like me or
all because my dad didn't treat me right
or because my mother my mom didn't hug
me and up or whatever it is it's
something externally that is in that's
preventing them from going where they
want to go and having what they want and
I say you've got to have a mind shift
there you got to have a shift that says
no no I'm responsible this is up to me I
get one run through life and I'm at the
end of the day what it's gonna be me who
determines how far I go and not somebody
else and so it's my fault as a common
phrase that I my clients will hear me
say all the time it's not Jaco video
isn't that famous good you know yeah
that's it everybody talks about Jocko
I've never seen an interview with him
I've not haven't read his book it's like
I I guess I should as much as he as much
as they gets talked about he's good so
he did one that I would recommend if you
want a first one that just completely
throws you in the deep end and allows
you to fully take a like Jocko in the
ass is the one that you did with the
Medal of Honor recipient his name
escapes me at Dakota Mayer right okay
and him and Dakota Dakota wrote this
book very very heartfelt and he just
talks through this particular experience
where he was restricted by the powers
that be for going back in to help people
he disobeys orders he goes back in and
he just starts fishing people and all
this stuff's going on but they this is
interesting especially for you as a
podcaster and for everyone that's
listening it'll be linked in the show
notes below it's phenomenal but I would
listen to it on a day where you're
feeling emotionally resilient makes it
quite intense and it's the podcast which
has got the best use of silence that
I've ever heard so they'll they'll leave
20-second batches with nothing being
said as they both just sit in this allow
this sort of sensation to swell as
Jacko's reading passages from the book
that kind of provides structure to what
they're talking about and Jacko's got
this like real growly quite kind of
intense voice
yet they're having this conversation man
it's it that one is a real especially
for yourself with your your military
background it'll be really really really
cool yeah I'll definitely go check it
out
you need to have totally the you were
talking about the fact that people
should take responsibility um what do
you think of some of the characteristics
that you see in the highest performers
within that domain the people that take
the most responsibility what what's the
sort of mindset that those people have
or what do they do that's of
commonalities yeah that's a really good
question I I think first and foremost
the people that I see you had the most
success at life and I'm not just talking
about financial success or wealth health
happiness relationships all all that
stuff first of all they have very long
time horizons so what we tend to see
across the board is people who are
people who come out of poverty let's
take just people who were born into it
and come out of it
here in America they have very long time
horizons they're thinking ten years
twenty years into the future people with
short time horizons people who think
only to the end of the week or the end
of the month or until next payday tend
to do very poorly because so one of the
things I see repeatedly of people who
are very successful is that they are
willing to they're willing to tust
suffer the slings and arrows longer than
most people and you know suffering and
pain that these are a really negative
grow you know gripping words but what I
really just mean is the ability to stick
it out and go through the the the hard
part so they can get to the good part
most people aren't willing to do that
because their time horizons are too
short so that's number one a second
thing that I noticed about really
successful people is that they don't
rely exclusively on their own the school
of hard knocks to learn skill so I'm
very fond I've been really focused on
I'll give you an example I've been
really focused on YouTube advertising
right now I think it's a very
underserved area where there can be a
lot of money can be made and so I've
been focusing a lot of time on
and the very first thing I did when I
knew I wanted to get up to speed on
YouTube advertising and how it was being
done was I went out and spent a thousand
dollars on a YouTube course from a guy
who was doing a lot of really cool stuff
in the space I found the best guy I
could to teach me how to do it and I
paid him why because that thousand
dollars is a is a penance to what it's
going to cost me if I have to go out and
learn it all from scratch both in terms
of time and the cost of testing so what
I find the most successful people will
do is when they want to go faster
they'll write a check and that's
something that I've tried to do since
the beginning of my career and and it's
something that I advise everybody else
do I'm a student first and foremost I've
always said I love being a student
because eventually if I'm your student
I'm going to know everything you know
and then I'm gonna know everything you
know and everything I know and I'm gonna
know the most right so this is kind of
this is my I I will buy your I will buy
your information I will buy your time
because in the end it leaves me better
off and so that's that's the second
thing that I see most people do then the
third thing is is that I think the most
successful people that I have that I've
seen in both life and business have a
joy about it
for the longest time I looked at my
business as a war it was something that
I fought and grunt you know got up every
day and I had to win like I had to win
you know on the battlefield and I
remember I sat down with a friend of
mine who was talking with me and
teaching me a little bit about how he
had built his business he had a brick
and mortar business and he looked at his
numbers every single week every week he
looked at the numbers and I said how do
you do that every week he's like you're
gonna be up and down all the time he's
like it's a game he's like I don't win
every week
but he's like it's fun to play I come in
and I look at my numbers every week and
every week I try and beat last week's
numbers and he said if I do that every
week I've had 20% growth a steady 20%
growth in my company every year since I
opened it up in like 1981 to give you an
idea of just how big this guy's
operation is now he said I've had 20
percent growth doing this every year
without fail come recession or
prosperity it's I always have it and he
said it's fun for me completely changed
my way of looking at my business and
about life it's just like dude life was
meant to be lived abundantly you're
supposed to have fun at what you do it
shouldn't be a grind you shouldn't hate
it and if it feels that way you're doing
something wrong and so those are I think
those are the three things that that
really I notice about people that I
admire and who I want to emulate as it
comes to life in business who is the
YouTube cosplay ah what's his name
John Penberthy he's a piece of Brit was
he cool Piven Athey yeah it's a it's a
really good course - by the way I
finished it up a while back but yeah
just in terms of everything he did and
everything was very simple - I really
like simple I don't like complexity and
so he's really gotten it down to a very
simple a couple of step formula that
allows you to track and retarget and and
I mean he even I didn't need the scripts
or anything like that but he had all the
scripts laid out so if you know nothing
about it going into it you can you can
build a pretty significant advertising
business on YouTube with without any
previous knowledge it's it's a good
course it's awesome month so how do you
find I wanna I want to get onto the long
term thinking so I think that's really
enjoy one but um before that how do you
find good coaches cuz everybody is
selling a course of some kind everybody
says I'm the Guru don't listen to him
his stuffs bollocks my stuff the real
[ __ ] I'll teach you what they won't
teach you I'll teach you it faster
cheaper quicker blah blah how do you do
that right because it's you trying to
sift through a lot of noise yeah at
first it's really hard I've been in this
business the you know online information
education and for I don't know 11 years
now and so I've been buying I probably
buy twenty or thirty thousand dollars
where the coaching every year and so
over the years you kind of learn uh yeah
that guy's full of it like I know I know
what he's doing here I know I
I know that sales trick and that you you
kind of get a feel for whether a guy
knows what he's doing or not in the
beginning I would I just committed to
learn a lot of stuff and so I think I
learned about courses yeah yeah you
learn right and here's here's the thing
listen I I rarely will do this but what
I tell people is you know it's wrong to
go and buy somebody's information go
through it and then just ask for a
refund
but if you go because oh it didn't work
for me well maybe you suck like maybe
it's not that it didn't work but if you
get into it and you're like no this was
not as promised like this isn't what he
told me I was gonna learn in this thing
then yeah just go get your money back
for it he should have told you you
should have been honest with you from
the beginning but I uh for this one in
particular not knowing much about
YouTube advertising because I haven't
ever done it what I did was I went to I
did some google searches I found some of
the some of the bigger names of guys who
are doing that professional sites and
all that you can kind of tell who's got
the professional funnels and stuff built
out and I went to I watched three
different webinars sat through six hours
of webinars and this and John's was the
one that I felt like this guy really
understood it better than the other two
at least that's what that was my
impression and so that's how I did it I
just went and watched three different
webinars on guys and learned a little
bit of knowledge and then bought a
course wouldn't it be cool if there was
a like hotels calm booking calm trusted
trader type oh yeah a central hub where
everybody could Glassdoor what their
opinions of online courses were I
thought be amazing you know every like
everyone would be from you Grant
cardones to your kid that's just started
out how to build a tick-tock Channel
thing you know you could submit yourself
on there and have verified purchases
that would be phenomenal be like Amazon
reviews for for online courses and that
would completely clear away this problem
hi and I wish somebody could do that
they do try that in the forex industry
for a while and they had a
thing I'll call for peace army or
something and the problem with it is and
the problem they had there was that you
get a bunch of guys who go in there and
they it's ultimately success or failure
as I said before it's really on you it
doesn't mean the course itself can be a
great course and if you don't have the
mindset to go win at that business or at
that particular skill you're never gonna
be successful at I mean John can teach
you step by step how to run YouTube ads
and if you don't go do it then you're
not gonna make any money or if you
shortcut it or if you expect to turn on
your first ad and have it make you $100
and give you a 5x return on adspend
then you know you're dreaming man
there's there's a learning curve
involved with that and so then they go
out and they're angry because oh that
guy spent $1,000 on this thing and then
I I did what he said and the money
didn't come in like it didn't just print
money day and night for me so he's a
terrible guy what a liar and a cheat and
I'm just like that I don't that kind of
thing really bothers me because having
worked with clients for you know 10 or
11 years and seeing the successes versus
the failures the failures are almost
always caused by the other person
not the course or the thing that they
took I mean I like I said I bought so
much stuff I'll buy it just to see
what's in it I spent $4,000 on a course
last year just to see what his back-end
funnel was right I just wanted to see
after I said what's going on yeah yeah
yeah I want to know what he's doing on
the backend cuz I know there's something
back there right so I do all kinds of
stuff like that and most of the time 99%
of the time the course delivers it's a
it's a decent course it's going to help
you out and the people who are
complaining about it are just there
that's what they are they're just
complainers compliance is number one
same with gym routines and meditation
and yeah and stuff like that it's
interesting that you mentioned about
finance have you followed the Wall
Street bets reddit subreddit do you know
what this is no ha Jason let me change
your life man so ah slash yeah what's it
what's the name of it it's our slash
Wall Street bets on reddit
and it's basically a subreddit that's
blown up recently I think Time magazine
or New York Times or something covered
it a couple of weeks ago and it's just a
bunch of people that make in sane calls
in the market like just ridiculous bet
with remortgage the house and do it just
for internet points with a bunch of
people that they're never gonna meet and
some of em some of them turn they'll
just be like oh I just made half a mil
yesterday off this one thing but then
more often than not people lose and then
there's a YouTube channel that does a
collection each quarter of the dankest
trades from Wall Street bets and it's
man it's so fun
once you turn on your go and have a look
because it will blow you away but they
were in the New York Times recently
they've been almost even manipulating
markets on penny stocks by putting
particular bits of advice into this huge
subreddit with millions of people in it
and then just going on a Robin Hood I'm
pumping the [ __ ] out of this and there's
like companies there's companies that
have 10x their value during this most
recent period where we've had a lot of
turbulence with the coronavirus stuff
and these companies have like 10x that
if I was just like some random
stationary company or whatever is that
you can trade that someone's just popped
in this subreddit man it's so funny well
that's that's not new I remember when I
first started trading I traded penny
stocks and there are actually there
there teams of guys who will go around
and they'll say that it only takes one
guy who really has a following of people
and he says ok we're all getting into
this thing now and you'll watch that
thing go from five cents to 45 cents and
and then what happens is as it goes up
all the guys is small network of people
ends up selling out as it's rallying
rallying rallying and then he says okay
I'm out and then the thing just crashes
back down and everybody's okay yeah
so we'd see that's that's not new that
is a it's a that's a pretty on the
regular thing that happens in the penny
stock world yeah did you see when John
McAfee was really big into
cryptocurrency a couple of years ago and
he was doing like McAfee's coin of the
week or something like that and he was
just making people's fortunes and then
yeah some guys from reddit and made a
bot that would scrape McAfee's Twitter
feed and Otto put trades on so they
could put a trade on what he'd tweeted
about before everyone else I'm like holy
[ __ ] it like this is you know some kid
in a basement somewhere bringing a
complete armored tank to war you know
what it is I that is that is a
get-rich-quick mentality that you that
you quickly give back everything that
you make in that world and in the
trading space especially if you don't
have a specific trading plan that has
been proven profitable over time and if
you don't go in and trade it every day
regardless of what's happening in the
market you are you're destined to fail
there's just no other way to trade it
probably invest too but certainly trade
professionally and and for the long term
than to ignore all of that other stuff
all of it all of that is short-term
profits and all of it they give back now
hey look if you can go in on one tray to
make three billion dollars or three
million dollars or whatever and be out
then more power to you man
but the number of people I work with
traders for about eight years and the
number of people who came to me and said
yeah I lost I've lost thirty thousand
dollars I lost fifty grand you know
doing this and and yeah oh I remember
one time I was up a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars and I lost it all plus
some more and I'm like my brother like
just that I've seen so many lives get
destroyed because people follow this oh
whatever the latest gimmick is that I
just it's such a turn-off to me and I
feel I feel for those people because I
know when I see this stuff oh I made X
number of dollars I'm like yeah but
you're gonna give it back in the
afternoon because you only you're only
posting your winners you're only
throwing those out there you're not
throwing out the losers that you
because if you did you'd be showing it
you know a completely different P&L at
the end of the month so few people can
take that win that they've had and just
be like cool I'm out like that's me
that's my one I'm gonna take the fact
that the one in a thousand chance of me
making three hundred and twenty thousand
dollars in a day happened and it's not
gonna happen again
so that's me yeah like that's me my
house my mortgage is paid off and my
misters got a new car and we're going on
holiday see you later on like you right
because they're naturally the the way
that the human brain wants those rewards
those unscheduled rewards right we just
want how I just if I take just another
little bit and you chip chip chip away
and then blown so yeah it's a high yeah
it's a high we were talking about a long
term thinking how people can have a
little bit better long-term thinking
obviously you know the last few weeks
financial markets and just generally the
geopolitical environment is in uproar
coronavirus and worries about what's
gonna happen with health care and with
food and there's I've seen images of
like Costco and stuff and there's aisles
are just completely empty with because
America or every America is secretly a
prepper and then everyone's a prepper
like on the down-low it's just now
they've finally got the excuse to be
able to go [ __ ] yes yeah we can use that
coming in the woods that we bought seven
years ago and yeah all those underground
stores of rice and stuff but yet so
we've got that and then you know you
think right we're coming out the back to
that which we will eventually go out the
other side of this and no one will talk
about it again what happens you know
you've got more uproar at the end of
this year you've got the the
presidential election going on and then
how do how do people deal with the chaos
of of life like that when they're going
to organize themselves I think when I
want to I said what I used to teach
trading to people so most of what you
see in the news in the markets is noise
it has no absolutely no relevance to to
anything and so you got to learn to
ignore most of that and what I see right
now with coronavirus with the elections
that are happening in 2022 Mia all of
that is no
people clearing the store shells to buy
rice like you're not gonna be able to
buy like suddenly you're not gonna be
able to buy corn I mean we produce we're
we're in the Grain Belt what do you need
what we live in we we feed the world
here in America what do we need buy corn
for right but yet for some reason we're
not gonna be able to get it and we got
to go clear the store shelves out it's
like all right fine all of that is noise
to me what's far more interesting is and
again thinking longer-term is what's
going to happen over the next 20 years
how is our how is our culture how is
technology going to change and how is
that legitimately gonna impact our world
and one of the things that we've seen on
on my show on Monday I took people
through the last four or five great
economic revolutions that happened and
evolutions that happened in just in
America starting in about 1784 and what
you've seen is over the last probably
fifty or sixty years is the timeline the
time it takes for us to chant for one
evolution to another from one major
transition to another is getting tighter
and tighter and tighter and what we're
in now is what I think is the greatest
market and economic evolution that we've
ever seen one that is going to make
roughly this sounds extravagant I
recognize but just that the numbers play
out is around forty six million jobs
obsolete I'm not saying that oh these
guys are gonna have a tough time or
their skills are gonna be out of date
I'm like you're not gonna need 46
million jobs in America over the next 20
years because either automation or
artificial intelligence will take over
those jobs and when I say artificial
intelligence people think you know like
a iRobot or something like that like
some so I Robot and that's not what I'm
talking about I'm talking about like in
the next 20 years there won't be a man
or woman alive in America who won't be
able to drive or won't purchase a
self-driving car that's artificial
intelligence that's the AI I'm talking
about
I remember reading remnants of a stock
operator when I was a kid
and the guy Jesse Livermore who was in
that story was rich enough that he drove
from his house to Wall Street every day
and he had a driver and I remember
thinking how cool would that be to be
able to have somebody drive you to work
and now in 20 years everybody's gonna
have the ability to do that it's it the
technology is already there and so what
other jobs that are less complex than
having to manage the the the literally
thousands and thousands of changes going
on in the environment when a car drives
down the road at every every second what
other jobs are gonna be obsolete how
many other people are not going to have
work well basically any factory work any
sort of like repetitive labor that has
to happen fast food low-income loggia
and and low middle-class jobs are gonna
go away and so what happens in that
transition well the middle class begins
to shrink and what we thought years ago
was that when that shrink happens and
when it starts to happen what we're
gonna have is very few people at the top
making tons and tons of money and then
this whole big swath of mankind living
in abject poverty and what we found is
is the opposite the middle class is
getting is getting smaller but the bulk
of that about 2/3 of them are moving up
into prosperity they're getting wealthy
or not poorer and it's because they're
seeing the transition and they're
responding to it but the change that's
gonna happen in my belief over the next
20 years is gonna be so drastic and so
fast that a lot of people aren't gonna
have the skills necessary to move up and
they're gonna end up being forced down
and so kind of my mission and the stuff
that I've been focusing on over the last
couple of years is is making my audience
my clients aware of the changes that are
happening and having them try and
disassociate from political change as a
way to improve our lives and improve our
well-being and focus more on individual
change what do I need to do to change my
life to make sure that over the next 20
years I prosper I thrive not that I
survive but that I actually thrive and
it's uh I mean it's a full-time job just
going
all that because we want to be focused
on the stuff that doesn't matter
we love focusing on the noise but the
noise doesn't make you any money the
noise doesn't protect you the noise just
distracts you
keeps you dependent and apathetic and so
that's that's kind of what my mission
has been over the last couple of years
you are right it's it really just feel
that we're at an inflection point you
know with what's what's what's happening
at the moment but then everyone said
that before everyone said the Industrial
Revolution I remember I got sent an
advert about the dangers of reading the
newspaper or reading books that was it
that the dangers of reading books would
disassociate man from his wife and it
would be the breakdown of the nuclear
family and then it was the same when
radio happened then the same when TV
happened and then the same when
telephones happened but what you said
there is right the cyclical iteration of
this is getting tighter and the
intensity is also increasing you know no
one would deny that a mobile phone has
more impact on our ability to focus and
connect with the people around us than a
book so you go oh let me give you yeah
let me give you an example of what I
mean because that is the typical
response that I get from a lot of
people's like oh they always say that
and I would always and they do always
they do always say that but let me give
you an example of what I mean over the
last thirty years or so since the advent
of computer technology and it started to
take a hold in the late in the late 80s
early 90s right so we're talking 30
years ago you could see the writing on
the wall in the auto industry and
anybody who was working in an assembly
line started to see jobs go away and be
replaced with automation and what they
should have done is recognized the
writing on the wall started learning new
skills so that they would be protected
when that transition happened when the
when they finally came and said here's
your pink slip we're closing the factory
we're moving it to Mexico because it's
cheaper labor or we replacing you with
the machine they would have been like no
problem I got something to fall back on
instead what they did was they put their
head in the sand they turned to the
unions and they
the union will protect us the union will
make sure we get our wages the union
will make sure we keep our pensions and
they've got they had 30 years it's why I
don't have any sympathy for any of these
people who are losing their jobs they're
like what am I gonna do now will you
have three decades to figure that out
but you just chose not to do it well
we're having that same sort of evolution
that same transition is hat is going to
happen in a multitude of industries as
more technology and and artificial
intelligence begins to take over more of
the repetitive work that we do as a
society today now that's gonna open up a
host of new opportunities for people to
be creative and to engage in work that's
fulfilling and exciting to them but
you're gonna have to learn some new
skills to be able to make that
transition and the time to do that is
not when they show up with your pink
slip that says hey thanks for working
here but you've been replaced you're
fired right that's not the time to start
working on this stuff and so that's kind
of been my message it's like yes a lot
of people are gonna survive this a lot
of people are gonna do well but it will
be those people who are taking steps now
and not waiting until they're out on the
street it's make sure that you're one of
them right make sure you're one of the
people who's there so what are some of
the skills if you were to create a new
human now and say I'm gonna imbue you
with skills that I think a robust as we
move forward over the next 10 and 20
years what would they be if you got a if
I had a kid who was coming to me and
saying hey I'm thinking about graduate
high school what skills do I need and he
didn't really know what he wanted to do
I would the first thing I would do is
tell Miller not code whatever the common
coding languages of the day it's it's
the best language that you can learn
because it does involve a great deal of
creativity just like writing if you
become a really good writer and creative
writer is a is a powerful tool a good
coder someone who is good at that and
has and can see the creativity of it can
can do really well the other stuff I
would focus on is what are the jobs that
will still be in high demand even after
repeated
work takes over it's taken over by
automation and those are gonna be the
jobs that require some sort of
creativity art science the things like
information I happen to think and I'm
somewhat biased when I say this so I
apologize to your audience but I happen
to think that the best business in the
world that anybody can get involved in
is the call it the knowledge business
the information business the consulting
or coaching business because we all are
good at something and it's a very cheap
and easy business to get started with
high profit margins and it's also
something that's going to be in a high
demand in years to come because as again
as technology evolves and it becomes and
evolves quicker and faster colleges will
not be able to keep up and you're
already seeing a lot of qalaat of
companies that are saying you know what
we don't really need this college degree
anymore I don't know what we were
thinking here but this check in the box
is really unnecessary what we want or
people would drive and skill that's what
we really need and people are getting
that from places other than college I
never went to college and when I wanted
to learn how to do YouTube advertising I
didn't go and take a college course on
it at night class right I went and I
found somebody who's doing it right now
who's successful at it and I paid him to
teach me everything that he knew and I
paid him a lot less than I would have
paid and it's in a lot less time than
going to a college class and so I think
it's a new industry and I wear it it's
already like two hundred and twenty
thousand dollars an hour gets spent on
information by small businesses alone in
America and I think that that's only
gonna grow over the next ten to twenty
years it's a good business and and it's
one I know inside and out so I got
coding we've got creative work which is
poetry science copywriting marketing I'm
gonna guess as well would be yeah
Photography is another great one
anything that requires a it requires
something other than repetitive skill it
requires a uniqueness to it that that
won't be able to be created by
artificial intelligence at least in our
lifetime what else do we do to survive
the 21st
spend less than you make and invest the
rest in things that you understand a lot
of books been written over the last 20
years on personal finance and it can be
reduced down to those two things it's
been less than you make save and invest
the rest and things that you understand
and if you don't understand anything
enough to save or invest in it then you
need to be investing in you build your
human capital your store of knowledge
and skill that gives you value to the
market those are the things that will
protect you over the long term you're
you're someone else's desire for you for
your knowledge or skill is what keeps
you safe in a changing environment okay
it is not you it's not a union that
protects a worker it's employers the
number one thing that protects a worker
are ten other people who want that
worker to come work for them that's what
really protects you and the greater your
and in the more marketable your skills
the more unique those talents are that
you have the more in demand you will be
and the higher the higher you'll be able
to charge for those skills so focus on
that as your primary mission and what
you'll find is that you'll never be out
of work you'll always be in high demand
and you'll always be pushing the maximum
of what you can charge in your industry
look tell new poets book be so good they
can take Milly yeah okay I always have a
version of these like mines like mine's
like be so valuable that they can let
everybody else that the company go but
you we can't let Tom go if Tom goes we
might as well shudder the company
because I can't do it without him right
yeah you need to be that guy you want to
be Tom feedback you know so I come it's
interesting that you said about the
other personal finance thing recently
had Morgan Housel on you know Morgan
from collaborative fund and you know I
banks ex writer for Motley Fool like is
he's good guy real real good guy I'll
link you and you'd love him your
absolute love it okay had him on and he
was talking about personal wealth and he
said wealth is the Ferrari that you
didn't buy it's the square footage in
the house that you didn't perch
so rather than the current shows of
wealth which are very externalize it's
the internalized ones right it's what
can you do that you can spend money on
which either creates more wealth or the
is liquid wealth that's there you know
money that's in your house money that's
in your bank account money that's in
actual assets you know it's funny I've
always said wealth is measured in time
not dollars so it's a it's a question of
if all of your income stopped today how
long could you survive before you had to
change your lifestyle whether it's a
week or a month or a year that's your
wealth you have one year of wealth you
have three months of wealth and that's
there's a there's a financial component
to that but it really changes the way
people think because if you make a
million bucks a year but you spend you
know nine hundred and ninety thousand of
it then you don't have a lot of wealth
you can't survive very long if your
situation changes and your income
changes and so very much the same thing
I like hearing he said that sentence he
said that for size same sentence okay
when you see the same thing from two
different spheres of awareness it's a
pretty good indication that it's the
truth
so yeah yeah absolutely agree more money
isn't there a stat that saw oh I've just
got something that says internal
temperature high allow it to cool is
that your is that your camera I've never
seen that we must here for an hour
I've had these cameras running a lot
longer than an hour so I don't know
what's going on do you think it could be
just the pure hot [ __ ] that we're
dropping on this episode it could be
yeah it could just be the you know that
this the knowledge we've been dropping
in here boy we really we really think
highly of ourselves
[Laughter]
yeah we'll see how much longer this
thing lasts that's that's crazy I gotta
look that up figure that out
so yeah Mogens saying about the fact
that you know people need to or does it
the statistic about how many Americans
have more than $500 I think in the bank
account or like $1,000 in a bank is like
some some incredible percentage of
people don't have oh yeah it's well over
half like 70 or 80% of the people
wouldn't be able to cover a
thousand-dollar bill if it happened yes
it's it's really insane and it's just it
goes to show you we tend to we tend to
live at our means and and it's one of
the reasons why nobody ever achieves
much wealth and then they want to
complain that that Bloomberg's got a lot
of it and it's like well you could have
more if you just spent less than you
made or you focused on acquisition of
wealth as a priority instead of instead
of what you are doing so anyway I don't
know I talked with a lot of people about
that aspect of it too because it's not
just about the making of the money it's
about the creating of wealth and not
what I call eating your children you
shouldn't leave your money you should
put it to work for you whether it's in a
business or in something else that you
understand I happen to put most of what
I make it back into my business because
that's what generates me the greatest
return and it's and so you know my
marketing dollars generate me a nice
return and I don't have to do much for
that so that's where I tend to focus
because that's what I understand it's
what I can control so that's what I've
always been interested in I get it what
about the other things that people need
so we've talked about the skills we've
talked about investing in ourselves and
our knowledge using some of the capital
that we have monetarily or in terms of
time to then convert it into knowledge
capital I suppose or skill capital that
we can then monetize off the back of
I've also spoken about the fact that
ensuring that you spend less than you
earn and that you invest in things that
you do understand are there any other
things that people need to be conscious
of as we move forward over the next 10
20 years what else are they looking out
for man I that's I think those are the
primary things I would love to just
continue to give your audience more and
more stuff to be worried about and to be
focused on but truth is if you can focus
on one thing and for any length of time
you're doing better than 90% of the
people around you so yeah those are
those are the things that I just I just
drill into people as I look things are
changing whether you want them to or not
control your income your freedom is
directly tied to the amount of wealth
that you have not just your mobile you
know mobility
right now I could fly to you and no
problem financially and no problem with
restrictions from governments I can
won't go to see you and you can come to
see me and nobody's gonna care about
that but for a lot of people that's not
a possibility because they don't have
the financial resources to do that and
if you don't have the financial means to
do it then you're not really free to
travel are you you're restricted by your
own limitations and so if you need an
example of this take Venezuela or you
know or I'm trying to think of or take
the middle east right and all the people
who are flooding into Europe now it's
not the poor and indigent who are able
to move out of these these terrible
places into America or into Europe it's
those who have money and those who have
money at freedom of movement even if the
borders are closed they can still find a
way wealth is Liberty wealth is freedom
and if you have it then then you are
free and if you don't then you don't and
so I I harp on this a lot because of a
lot of my audience a lot of people are
attracted by message are people who are
very libertarian in nature and they tend
to want less government and more quote
unquote freedom and I try and explain
look government shouldn't be the focus
you should be the focus because your
freedom is more directly tied to your
ability to move than it is anything else
you know I have not only financial
freedom but I also have mobility freedom
Maya my business is transferable so I
could pick up everything that I have
today we could clean this whole thing
out I could put it on a truck I could
ship it overseas or around the world I
could be back up and running with a
camera and a laptop tomorrow as long as
I got an internet connection my business
doesn't stop my money doesn't stop
nothing so people say aren't you
concerned about what's happening in
America and aren't you concerned about
the election no because if it gets bad
I'll just leave and I'll take everybody
I love with me why because I have the
wealth to do that I have the wealth
freedom to do that and most people don't
and so I say instead of trying to figure
out a change
government and how to fix the
Constitution or fix our culture why
don't you start by trying to fix you and
making sure that you're in a position to
protect you and your family no matter
what happens and then once you've done
that once you try and convince as many
people to do the same now that you are
an example worth following because
that's the biggest problem is that the
first question people ask you is is well
why should I listen to you I mean you
would not be talking to me right now if
the if if I had if I couldn't
demonstrate that I could live the values
that I talked about because otherwise
people wouldn't pay any attention to me
like I don't know who this nutjob is
living in his basement down by the river
with his parents but that guy hadn't
worth listening to that's that's the
mentality you have to have we all have a
lot more control over what we do then
the second-order effect of trying to
influence policy government social
standards all the rest of the things
yeah yeah it's that kind of radical
responsibility that personal sovereignty
having agency as it's called a good
heuristic actually this is a cool
thought experiment that one of my
buddies came up with he says to work out
the friend or friends that you have that
are the highest agency within your
friends circle imagine that you were in
jail you're in jail you've been placed
in jail wrongfully and you need to get
out and you've got 24 hours to get out
who do you call like that person that
you call is the one that has the agency
right there have upward mobility they're
able to think laterally and orthogonal E
they're able to you know and it's like
those are the people those are the
people that are gonna win they're the
ones that are robust yep they're that
that's again that's the circle that you
want yeah as many people that can break
you out of jail as is possible yeah and
and that you you want that kind of
mastermind team it's so sad that
mastermind gets overused the way it
really have it's it's such a waste now
to even use that term but the truth is
you want to surround yourself with
people who are like that industrious
successful people who you can draw from
and who you can add value to so yeah
absolutely couldn't agree more
Jason man we made it we made it through
we did it man I really enjoyed this
thank you so much for having me on a
show it was sick man why should people
head they want to check out you stuff
why do they go well the show I keep
referencing is called wealth power and
influence and you can get it wherever
you get your podcasts and then if you
want to know more about this if any of
this sounded interesting to you I got a
great like two-hour presentation that I
gave to about 600 of my clients just not
maybe a month ago and you just go to
control the source com control the
source calm it's basically just designed
to help people discover what helps with
the negative feedback loops and stuff
that people struggle with and it also
helps them kind of figure out what
they're good at so what are those the
knowledge and skill that you already
possess what what is this stuff that's
the creativity that you have because a
lot of people say I don't know what I
would do I'm not good at anything
well that's nonsense and and after the
presentation they can it kind of helps
draw that out and helps put them on a
path and so I had a lot of fun teaching
it they people got a lot out of it so
having go check that out of control the
source and yeah those are the two things
awesome on everything that we've spoken
about we were linked in the show notes
below you already not to do like share
and subscribe but for now Jason man
thank you so much for your time
oh thank you for having me really
appreciate
[Music]
you